[Music]
so girls we're gonna introduce ourselves
fans I'm Jessie and I'm a london-based
presenter I'm poppy and I am an
entrepreneur and I have a mental health
app called happy not perfect I'm have
you ever disorder and I have my own
business as well now both of you ladies
have created empires and there's so much
more to come hashtag girl bosses have
you talked to me about skin and your
other businesses my business started a
year and a half ago and it went viral
because of how inclusive it was and it
was so different nobody's seen anything
like it before
coffee you have done so much but the
most recent thing you've just launched
your yeah I think it was just realizing
how much we're all suffering and stress
and anxiety is at an all-time high our
generation it's reported to be the most
stressed out that's ever lived so that's
why I created happy not perfect the app
to give your mind a full kind of workout
when we're so busy going to the salon
and having treatments all the time do
you find that that is your timeout or do
you actually prefer to just do it in
your own time most times I like to do it
at home on my own feel like I'm saving
time saving money and I love the fact
that I'm in my home using my visitor and
I feel like I can just do it before bed
or in the morning looking after yourself
it's just a few minutes thinking about
you and how you're gonna nurture
yourself and so you not only look better
but actually feel better because yeah
you've taken that time for you what
makes you feel confident when you're
working I have to say it's definitely
been my biggest challenge in the in the
last two years and I think it's
sometimes so easy to think so honors
confidence and actually underneath they
don't and the biggest lesson that I've
been learning myself as having more
inner belief in your ideas education is
so powerful isn't it when we're learning
and when you're asking questions I think
that needs to be spoken about more and
it takes work and that's that thing I
think is so important about these things
is that everybody has impostor syndrome
in some form or other
the phrase impostor syndrome I think
it's something that so many people
experience and people that you wouldn't
even think and it's this feed
of being a fraud it's feeling of right
now you could be sitting here going why
am I here what am i doing I feel like we
underestimate ourselves sometimes I
worked with some amazing meditation
teachers to create meditation series
about this about really remembering kind
of our value and our worth the women
that really value themselves I think is
the biggest superpower a woman can
absolutely do you look up to anyone or
do you have a mentor yes I have so many
mentors I feel like I collect mentor
yeah so I get so inspired by someone and
then I've asked people straight out I'm
like can you be my mentor because it
makes such a difference just to have
someone you trust you admire maybe
they've gone through the same thing I
love asking for advice yeah and that's
such an important thing like I feel like
people were too scared nowadays to ask
for that advice and go actually can you
help I have friends I ask advice from
which I think I kind of like mentors to
me because they're always there for me
whenever I need to I need any hope and
being women in this industry do you find
that we are getting there with equality
do you think that 2018 has been a year
for the women oh my gosh 2018 has been
incredible for women and all these
incredible female actresses what you
know standing up for each other or
wearing black I feel like we're become
we're being heard a lot more this year
it's inspiring to see so guys I could
literally sit here and we could talk
whatever but we're gonna have to wrap it
up thank you so much for joining me
today has been a
amazing I feel like it's been a real
insight into other women in this
industry and it's so nice to actually
meet them I had a really enjoyable day
it was very different and fast-paced but
I really loved it and it's something I
definitely do again oh my gosh those
girls are the definition of inspiration
they have their own businesses the
influences the super honest and
authentic makes you to look so alive
when you're with people you would just
just get real